hi so today I wanted to make a really
short video about how to structure the
writing for your discussion so I'm now
in my third year of my PhD and I've
written a couple of papers and I really
noticed that writing the discussion can
be the hardest part but also the most
satisfying part and I think it's also
the part where you can show most of your
creativity as a researcher and as a
thinker so if you want to have some tips
and tricks on how to structure writing
the discussion let's get straight into
it so first of all when you write your
paper I think it's best to write it from
the inside out and that's to say that
you first write your results then the
methods afterwards the introduction and
finally the discussion and the reason
for this is that if we start with
writing the discussion we often don't
have a clear idea of what the most
important findings are of our paper our
paper usually has three four or even
five findings and just listing all these
findings is not that interesting you
usually want to show it kind of as a
narrative story in your discussion and
really try to think about the bigger
implications of your findings and that's
why we usually write the discussion last
then the second tip is to really take a
step back when you're writing your
results so don't immediately start
writing your results down but really try
to take a step back back and think about
what your results show and mean in a
bigger Contex of the existing literature
right now so usually what I do is I
write for every paragraph the main
finding and then I try to find if these
findings are confirmed by previous
literature or if they actually maybe
show the opposite from previous
literature which also sometimes happens
and then you try to kind of make a list
of literature that you can find that
confirms or maybe shows the opposite
from your results and see how your
results fit within this wider narrative
that is currently happening within the
scientific field and depending on how
big your topic of interest is or how big
your topic of research is you may have
to go through quite a lot of literature
to truly get a sense of where your
results stand but diving into this
literature really will give you an
understanding of The Wider field and
also an understanding of which bits and
parts are still missing so for example
right now we're writing an paper on
Parkinson's disease and we found that
certain cortical thickness areas and
also subcortical volume areas were
similarly degenerating in the
Parkinson's group as has been previously
found by other papers but we also found
an area that actually wasn't really
found in previous papers with Neuro
Imaging but has been found when we look
at more pathological studies and this is
quite interesting and also something
that we are quite excited about but yeah
I would really recommend you to try to
see where your results stand in the
wider literature and this brings me to
the third tip and that is to discuss it
with colleagues of yours that have more
information and this may be a professor
or maybe a fellow PhD student but when
you explain your results to them and
really try to explain to them where you
think your results stand and where you
think your results lie you can kind of
gauge if your narrative makes sense to
another expert in the field because
quite often to us our narrative is
really clear and makes a lot of sense
but to another PhD student or a
professor it may be a little bit less
unclear or maybe they have
recommendations of certain literature
that you've neglected or haven't read
about yet and that would be really good
to be aware of before you start writing
your discussion or before you submit
your paper then another paragraph that
you usually always have to write is the
shortcomings and limitations so this is
usually one short paragraph where you
describe all the limitations that your
study had and it's good to hear be
really honest about the limitations that
your study had and it's fine if you have
a lot of limitations like studies are
never perfect there will always be
future avenues that have to be
researched and discovered and I
personally as a researcher find these
parts quite interesting to read to
really see which parts were neglected in
a study or weren't considered yet and
also where I can contribute if I decided
to research this topic B so think about
what kind of shortcomings your study had
and that can be for example maybe a
limited sample size or maybe you didn't
include a certain covariant in your
study then there's usually also a
paragraph about the wider societal
impact and this doesn't always have to
be the case but for my field usually we
do include this because we're working
with patient groups so it's also good to
see how our results would affect these
certain patient groups and just try to
consider how your results could impact
for example clinical process sesses or
other parts of society that should be
considered one final tip that I have
that always really helped me with the
discussion is to write the discussion
down in the form of a mind map so trying
to walk yourself through your results by
mind maps or by visual images and try to
link every part of the literature that
you found to these visual images kind of
in a wordcloud and I find doing this
process it takes a really long time but
it's very satisfying and it also really
gives you a snapshot overview of what
your results mean in The Wider context
so if you have other tips for writing
the discussion please let me know cuz
I'm currently in the process of writing
my discussion and I always find the tips
that you guys have very helpful as well
so finally something else that I wanted
to mention is that we're currently
looking for a video editor and an
animator for different types of videos
on Neuroscience cuz I want to in the
future make a few more videos dedicated
to computational neuroscience and I
would love to have someone else on the
team that can help me with this so if
you love editing or you love animating
videos I will post a job description
down below and you can apply through
there and otherwise see you next week
bye